If x is a whole number, what
other sets does x belong to?
And we saw a couple of videos
ago that I mentioned that the
notion of the set of
whole numbers is
a little bit ambiguous.
Sometimes whole number means
non-negative integers.
And sometimes it means
all integers.
But in this context, and I
actually looked at what the
writers of this question are
looking for and the standards
that they care about.
So from their point of view,
when they refer to whole
numbers, they're referring
to non-negative integers.
So they're referring to 0, 1,
2, 3, so on and so forth.
And I also looked at what they
referred to-- And remember,
this is just according to the
writers of this question.
This isn't according to how
everyone views these things.
But they view natural numbers as
just the positive numbers.
I told you two videos ago that
some people view natural
numbers as just the positive,
but some people include 0 as a
natural number.
But in this context it's just
the positive integers.
I shouldn't have said positive
numbers, I should have said
positive integers.
It obviously doesn't
include the numbers
in between the integers.
So natural are there the numbers
in this context.
You'll see other contexts where
this would be described
as natural.
In this context the natural
numbers are 1, 2, 3, 4, so on
and so forth.
And of course, there's no
ambiguity about what integers
are; everyone agrees on that.
Integers are-- you know, you
could go arbitrarily negative
and then negative 3, negative
2, negative 1, 0, 1, 2, 3.
And you can just keep going
in the positive direction.
So if x is a whole number, when
they say whole numbers
they mean it is non-negative.
What other sets does
x belong to?
Well, if it's a whole number,
it's anyone of these numbers.
And all of these numbers
are also integers.
The set of whole numbers, by the
convention they're using,
is this set right here.
It is a subset of integers.
So we know that x is
also an integer.
x is also a member
of integers.
That means a member,
a member of a set.
x is also a member
of integers.
But it will not be a member of
natural numbers, or at least
the way that they've
defined it.
Because x could be 0.
0 is considered a whole number,
but if x were 0, it
would not be a member of
the natural numbers.
So we can't say it's natural.
All we can say is, that it's
definitely integers, it's
definitely rational.
Because any whole number, you
can just divide it by 1 and
represent it as a fraction.
So x is a member of rationals.
And of course, it's also a
member of the real, which is
the broadest set that
we know of.